welcome to the iron Lords podcast
episode number 23 it's another glorious
Sunday and we've got a lot to discuss so
we're gonna get right into it
I want to introduce a lord who I
consider a friend of the round table
and I pleasure to meet in the flesh at
e3 2015 we broken bread together with
Lord King and Lord ruler and even had a
chance to chuck down some elder scrolls
need a minute various events he's also a
multi-platform owner and I always
respect his different take when it comes
to gaming politics and issues in the
community introducing the indie dev guru
and the silent partner of the tech
podcast fellow destiny warlock fan
fellow particular Chicago Bulls fan
mother Lord be money 101 how we doing
sir yo ridiculous I'm glad to be here
appreciate the invite absolutely
absolutely and of course we have the
usual suspects at the round table
my co-host with the co-host my brother
from another mother 9 a grill gamer
himself my man Lord addict how we doing
sir nothing just checking out the social
space you are allowed out to Bungie for
dropping their social space promotion
the solo gamer who lives with a
single-player experience semi offline
xbox profile Illuminati I needed to get
through the old blood
as a single play experience god I feel
you have to do it otherwise hey get that
I just like the Bob I think especially
with the destiny beta out there
everybody sending you invites on my holy
let me finish this first let me go and
[Laughter]
of course the XS gamer o the Lord who is
a man of his convictions demands nothing
less than the premium experience Oh
beloved Lord King how are we doing sir
you don't fantastic today good another
glorious Sunday I can't wait to get into
these topics baby we got money in the
bill oh so you know it's gonna be crazy
so I am Laura kognito spreading that
game umbrellas here in the ILP not
telling you what you want to hear but
what you need we got more great things
lined up so before you start I just want
to know what all the Lord's playing
these days and these gaming streets are
start would be money what's been on your
radar we haven't even playing this week
just this week man I've just been on a
destiny beta you know it dropped on
Tuesday ps4 so I've just been rocking
out on there and then got the Xbox
version so played it on there I actually
was just playing before I hop don't hear
so good that's where I've been that man
so though of course what's going on it's
not adequate plan I'm gonna join them in
that they're releasing another like this
is like the eighth well eight is a
little BIG's a dream but they're
releasing another leader an AI that died
in the first one so
oh wow wow they still support it that's
what's up
I never get another leader net we get
two missions this month a leader in the
next month we get a mission another
leader
a grunt leader actually and then after
that that's when the their expansion
starts um Lord addict so do you suggest
when I purchase the game I get the whole
package the big shebang yes because if
not if you don't get the season pass if
you buy all of the leaders individually
it's like the cost of the game again oh
and I feel like that I feel like a lot
of people are doing that that's not
really understanding what's going on so
they're getting like they're paying for
the game twice sovereign would have you
been playing offline this week great
game except for the last boss the last
boss is freaking horrible like like like
when anybody plays it when you get to
that boss you're just gonna be reminded
of of them what's his name um doomsday
from Batman or Superman just wow wow
yeah but the game is great I'm a little
more FirePro on the PC and of course the
destiny to beta I definitely got in
there i touched up everything Wow today
though Lord King but a playing this week
well I'll put down the zero horizon done
I don't know if I'm going to go back to
that give me that push my blood-borne
and stuff is still looking at me so I'm
going to really dedicate myself to that
PlayStation because I put that
downstairs and the man came solo away
from the Xbox as I noticed if I'm in
front of a TV and I have the choice
between an Xbox and a PlayStation
PlayStation doesn't even get looked at
so yeah I'll put it downstairs by itself
so it can you know have room to breathe
that I'm going
I'm gonna you know get into that cuz
that's gonna be my space down there but
um I've been playing a destiny to beta
and you know I play my battle islands I
cannot stress this enough is a
free-to-play game I would like everybody
that's listening to the podcast to just
you know download the game yeah it's a
real good it's very addictive you can
join your groups your clans and stuff
like that and I like going and stealing
people's money when they sleep wake up
surprised that I stole a million plus
from them and you know and they got a
chance to retaliate and if they fail
then I can just go right back in a
wallet is a good thing for me I like
I've been rocking out I got the two two
I was able to download that got a good
deal from Best Buy dance I was rocking a
little bit came out yes you did came out
Friday and Friday midnight digital and
just a word of advice y'all for those
who just pick it up who do not like
motion controls you are screwed for the
first ten minutes because the tutorial
is in completely in motion controls you
cannot get out of it until you finish
the tutorial it is annoying I tried
everything
they just got to work on that but I
think not picking it up now after the
first once you get over there like me
money said you can just turn that off
you can disable in handheld mode you can
disable it you know you know when it's
docked and then from the game is really
fun why is it every day you know does
something good right we fail to realize
this is a Nintendo they still have they
all messed up ways so you know we gotta
allow our concessions for that we they
all we thought they were you donate all
I knew
you know yahoo we thought so I've also
I've been going hard with like a boxer
like Vallecano Nemo Heroes I've been
really getting into it yeah free to play
Diablo style so much fun you know get
your heroes on so if you're a marvel fan
you got to do it it's free you can't
complain at least up to level 2 so I've
been rocking man um also dusted off the
tacky okay we getting the skills back I
got a shop up for be money I see it hurt
his Lilly's out there in these streets I
got it I got a low times and it makes
you I must admit I can't wait for the x4
that version because you can see was
that you should play kill a Moroccan so
I just wanna only start also want to
talk about on last week's poll last week
poll results are in and the people have
spoken
the winner of the October 27th murderers
row poll in a highly contested battle
was Assassin's Creed origins at 39%
Wolfenstein to tame in a very close
second and 35% disrespecting the Lords
opinion of Bethesda the for the poor
Mario was about a hundred and ninety-two
almost two hundred votes we have people
in the poll and I want to thank everyone
for actually participating we got a new
poll cooking up at the end of the show
so stay tuned at the end for that but
we're gonna get into these types we I
like to talk about so first
obviously we know that the destiny to
beta is upon us this week and there's
been a lot going on with that so I want
to bring this to the round table as far
as the the story I want to talk about
that villain dominus goal and I was
following the Lord's opinion of the used
to feel likes and dislikes I want to
start off with be money says Lord addict
didn't know beat money is that Destiny's
life is about that destiny likes money
what's your overall feeling that is beta
and story and such so far I think
overall I think is gonna be pretty good
you know I mean it's definitely more
story content than there was with the
vanilla destiny you know the gameplay is
is top-notch gunplay it is second to
none I mean the one thing I would say is
that the some of the multiplayer stuff
feels like a little bit off whoo with it
being like four before I would vote it
kept it like 66 or maybe even expand it
to like eight or something like that but
like just playing when they drop you
into the story you know they started
right into the action which is good you
know it's not really tutorial or
anything like that and then you know I
mean the big villain he's a badass you
know I mean takes all your life he's got
the ledge you know I mean he's gonna be
something to be reckoned with so I'm
looking forward to it September 6 can't
come soon enough to me absolutely
absolutely so as far as I would actually
be money not as far as like the um the
actual villain dominus goal and you know
like for the people I guess because
obviously we're destiny lovers so do you
think the people who were either on the
fence with destiny or just like anti
destiny far as the story that's the big
knock do you think that it helped its
case or do you think it's still gonna
remain the same status quo like what you
feel about that I think people who
really aren't into it it's not really
gonna affect them at all you know I mean
they'll look at it and they'll see you
know cuz every destiny expansion had
some big villain mm-hmm so they'll just
kind of look at it like that
you know it's just a another character
that you know be gone by the first
expansion and you know there'd be some
other big villain or whatever the case
is so it may not affect them as
much unless they start promoting it a
little bit differently if they put they
put Gaul out there and as far as TV
promotion and things like that Google
and make it make people understand that
he is the big boss of destiny to them
maybe you know people start taking a
little bit more notice to it but other
than that they'll just you know pacify
and say there's definitely 1.5 like I've
been seeing for the most part satisfied
we just got to get them a little bit
more enthused about the multi-plane
right you just watched your six is back
I mean the 66 felt so good last time you
know I mean like it seems you know
because they don't put the two modes in
their collective maps are pretty big
control you know still feels good what
did you try to talk down yeah yeah
countdown like I wished that with 66 you
know I mean I feel like you know some of
those matches go a little quick just
because it is four and then depending on
you know the cake the people that you're
playing with so like if you go in there
with randoms like just going there and
getting trashed you know I mean and it
becomes pretty difficult so you know
that's the one thing with that was that
moto we probably want to play with your
boys you know some kids would know how
to play the game otherwise you know just
get frustrated
absolutely absolutely cool so any of the
red other Lords want to jump in on their
destined to bethe impressions for making
it absolutely difficult for maybe I
think it was 20,000 people that had a
hard time downloading your beta and I
got nothing but the runaround when I was
talking to Xbox Microsoft yeah I know
you tried your hardest a few - you know
you you guys never hear me go off like
this but I was absolutely 100%
frustrated I gave you $100 and $100 was
clean when the cake though right
when that car ran fantastic when it came
due right it was very eager to steal my
money and walk away very fine and you
promise me everybody else but guess who
wasn't playing look at the screen I was
so why is it that I support these idiots
all the way to 100% I was down with you
from this day destiny launch I brought
the big package I even went out and
brought that Ghost that I couldn't find
off for eBay $400 let's let's break down
this issue Lord kids gimme you have a
light but yeah your plate so my question
is now I remember when we were going
through that whole baby thing the file
download wasn't the normal 15 gigs for
you right it was like a small right
megabytes Wow now when you try to launch
that file it was get was it giving you
like one of those weasel or the school
got something other than go to the
school you're joining now hold on now
they have a website it's called the game
again I said wow that sucks I do
remember when we start like yeah you you
had major issues or some of the forums
people were saying that first day was
was pretty much was pretty brutal for
some people yes sir yeah
sir so everything I settle with
Microsoft I did I deleted that other
purchased got to Bunji Bunji called me
Bungie text me Bungie tweeted me I went
to sleep I got an email uh when I was
sleeping
shoutout to Lord uh hot monkeys love him
[ __ ] back send me he said get on I'm
jumping on he had just started his
download I told him what I was doing I
had the problem that I saw the email the
email said click on this link I clicked
on the link let me tell you what they
told me in this link hold B when you
press a to download okay interesting
cleared it up Wow interesting that is
the weirdest fix I've never anything
like that you can load it up okay they
secretly blaming it on you they on the
low this podcast so fast let me give you
my impression of the game after I got a
chance to play I got in like I said
before I played the PC version so my
initial reaction is to compare it to the
PC that I played they gave me more story
more story than in the PC version that I
got cuz we get to play a little small
section in the PC this was a extended it
was a little bit more flushed out stuff
made sense to me now I was like ok the
story makes sense this makes sense that
part makes sense though the graphics is
comparable guys not taking anything away
from me I'm playing around 4k screen but
the graphics are comparable to the ones
that I was played on the PC the pacing
was good do I feel that it's a super
step I don't have the full game to give
that assessment at this time so I'm all
shortchange them
and I don't think from from the soil
sample size that I received that I've
been comment on how vast the story has
improved to be honest with you the first
mission captivates you yes yes you
started started the juices flowing the
multiplayer we played I suck at
multiplayer imma let everybody know I
suck at multiplayer because I don't put
the effort in to play it but this
multiplayer felt vastly different as law
kognito can attest I came in at the top
of the leaderboards at one match and the
playing offer your teammates and the
co-operative the way you use your supers
and your specials and the weapon loadout
and setup we thought it was something
minor when they put two primaries in
that's not minor at all it vastly
changes the dynamic of the game
absolutely I agree with you 1,000 on
that absolutely this is one point to
know because I felt it felt fresh new
and exciting so did it felt like destiny
- yes it felt like destiny - so yeah
cool so overall side outside of the
crazy issue getting in and bungees
foolishness with the beta but we didn't
like the product alright I love the
product can't wait to September no doubt
no doubt
oh Lord addict I don't get you want to
get you in there have you been feeling
about said beta I mean you know I didn't
really I played everything they had
offer I played some PvP today I'm trying
to stay away from it for the most part
because I don't want to like OD on the
little content we do have now and then
you know it's not like I won't play it
on launch but I want to feel is you know
new to the project is possibly can but
you know when it comes to your single
play it looks like they've really
established a narrative you know they
definitely kick this because that's the
you know that's homecoming is the first
mission of the game and homecoming is a
way better mission than the first dip
mission two deaths that he absolutely so
you know this
since orcs we haven't really had a good
antagonist you know we just have yeah so
I'm glad that you know golf or Gary he's
he's really really extra like Gary Gary
will mess you up you don't care if you
could sell like he I do think it was
awfully convenient he walks out there
when you when your light goes away but
you know what that I digress I'm not
good even argue but you know so he walks
out there and he starts just manhandling
you around this entire platform and he's
just kicking you like 10-15 feet every
time he kicks you I mean he's just
straight up like this is my [ __ ] they
say chores I mean you've never seen any
of the enemy factions to really dominate
the Guardians like this you know you
know he has all of them straight up like
I don't know what to do mm-hm I mean who
knows what happened to the speaker so I
mean they they have enough of those
hopefully they killed that Charlotte II
you want to pick it up just to find out
what happened to the speaker you know
why is he showing up now how did he get
through all of their defenses it's like
y-you know what is he using to absorb
the light from the traveler where is the
light going so you know they they have a
lot of mysteries which destiny one
didn't you know for the most part
destiny mocked itself and you know that
was always making fun of themselves so
you know and you know what some of the
biggest things about destiny one that
really intrigued me that I was really
you know what's what's going on was like
the stranger not the street yeah the
stranger it's stuff like that and that's
completely out of everything like that
shuttle upend and its lady pan into chat
she said of Garrett Gary's a monster
like one of the big moments I knew I was
messing with destinies when Sivan went
up there and he looked at the window you
know it's convenient he went to the
window the moment they valiree were
playing
on this place but and he was just like
everybody all me puts up that bubble and
then like they just start which you know
I will say I'm a little bit less of a
cave fan after he goes and guns and
tries to shoot big like that makes no
sense like what were you shooting at
that's from I'm really really excited
about the characters down you know I
don't know about the war because how do
you feel about enough listen the ship
came in and had to drop and it did
she jumped on a ship she just ret that's
outside that moment the only moment I
had him a car that was either memorable
was when taking King dropped in the way
she was describing it and helping you
harness that was to me one of her best
moment I felt like the connection to the
character but he's that you know he's
that noble you know I knew things that
he'd be ran my way I feel like this
needs to be my way you got Kade with
that silly you know egotist ornery yeah
you know that silly Christy personality
he's gone and that you know I feel like
she needs that you know I think her
story is this one she needs Warlocks
need to be like the master race for
warlocks need like that's the kind of
storyline don't want from her I want
like arrogance from her I want her to
think that you know warlocks are doing
it is no sin bro like you don't get to
send fail from uh that's not yeah I
don't balance in any plane three years
what I've gotten from from her and I'm
cuz you're not a warlocks on every class
sir yeah I know see no I'm warlock
anyway balances between the buffoon and
the stone man like he's all rigid and
stone and this buffoon is like a
rubberband spaghettini recorded or
spaghetti noodle stuff I want she's the
balance I want for statements like she
made on taking King like a more of a
personality where she's like we need
a warlock on that dreadnought like I
want more areas like that like where I
feel like she would be a good like you
know if it's not my warlock
well she's just too late like she I
don't think she just has a prize I think
I still trying to define her character
like I want that feeling when she walks
in you know she don't be like you guys
can't do this warlocks could have took
that little eyes let's give destiny to a
chance to flush her out because she does
have her own store that apparently all
the Vanguard's they do split up in
destiny - thank you go to the each plan
and I believe the plan of she's home but
it has like a lot of deep more bleeding
where first what a trial or something
yes so let's give it up but we've been
talking a lot I want to get lawyer
sobbing I mean I thought to touch on PvP
real quick okay chopping my PvP thing is
like you know a lot of people were
really skeptical with the four before I
agree I feel like you know I personally
love for before I think they need to
keep that as their competitive you know
johner but I think they need a casual
playlist that's the same thing is the 44
but at 66 I think all the weapons are
way more balanced than I've ever been
you know you with your leader abilities
you can have rude like me and you know
big bad Ron 77 we were playing both
Titans he had the little Barry I had the
big barriers so we would set them up
side by side it has like literally a
three a 45-degree angle shield and he
would get to left it and then I get the
right and said you're so like I like the
you know the Senate Reaper team behind
that you know the power ammo makes it to
where you're not getting [ __ ] killed
all the time
so I think if you would skill in once in
you know destiny to one was like a six
or a five or six because there's a lot
of problems with destiny and destiny -
is like a seven to nine because it's
it's that fluid but it's just the beta
that Bungie has plenty of time to mess
everything up
what's the destiny connoisseur for your
opinion on this data alright alright so
let's start with the initial story
mission homecoming so got in there um
honestly graphically it looks great to
me fantastic to me the rain effects I
you know ran smoothly um the gunplay is
still on point down the track is live
yeah soundtrack is definitely lit long
when you get to the tower you're
defending the tower with Zavala and you
see all of this red Legion just dropping
and dropping and dropping I was
expecting like slowdown and craziness
and honestly it came off without a hitch
and beautiful mom so I was very
impressed with that um one thing that
I'm kind of dissenting on in comparison
to what you guys are talking just
talking about his story wise like story
wise I'm confident they're gonna have a
lot more story no but maybe maybe maybe
it's the knee though like I'm not big on
the one-liners like the dominance
statements and like it just it comes off
it comes off like overly corny like you
know okayed one liners even Zavala with
all of these like show them what
Guardian is it doesn't it doesn't
resonate with me same thing with Gaul
alcohol caught you up at the top of the
tower he kicks you off he says some real
dominant stuff to you and I can I get it
but it just doesn't feel it doesn't feel
grounded to me obviously I mean you find
space aliens and that doesn't there's a
certain level of of suspension of
disbelief but I know it's just like in
the dialogue and stuff like that it just
seemed kind of over the top and I hope
that's not the whole thing
um but in terms of the action in terms
of the action it seemed fantastic to me
um the PvP that I played I also suck at
PvP I'm horrible at PvP but that I'm
going in honestly I'm going in with it
with like a halo mentality
you can't doing this because when let's
say I was playing on control that's when
you're in control you're going through
all these points that ABC and and deal
whatnot and trying to control them and
it's like I was just running it with my
face out all the time right in halo you
run around and you can you can count on
two or three of of two different types
of grenades just sort of strength around
throw and then injure people and then
come in and pick people off you can't do
that in destiny you have one grenade
that you have and then you have to you
have to think about how you utilize that
and then strafe around the area to try
to pick people off so in terms of
strategy is different so it took some
getting used to I got better towards the
end but I was still getting getting
handed so it seems fun like it seems
like I can't really speak to how much of
a jump it is some destiny when I played
some and I played some destiny one more
recently um so all I can speak to is
graphically it looks it looks better it
looks to be running bad looks like it
can handle more and I just hope like
everything they do include in terms of
story is good story it's just not like
you know kind of popcorn sci-fi stuff
they mentioned I you know that they felt
like it may be too much story so yeah I
don't know you know what that meant by
that statement but hopefully it is a
good story
is it the black colleges could take you
people I'm sorry now I hope it's not
just fluff you know I mean I hope it's
nice you know just nonsense I hope is it
actually pertains to destiny lore and
you know I mean really what I want and I
think they need to really aim for when
they do these destiny expansions and you
know there's vanilla destiny to is
whatever that expansions about could
they got better towards the end of you
know destiny one wolf you know rise of I
I want that entire you know the entire
point of the expansion done like you
know I feel like destiny to you know the
main story should be about you you know
you know you're fighting your way back
to take the tower back to take the last
city and you're trying to find you know
Gary I'm gonna kill coffee area
but you know you try to find him you're
trying to find out what's he doing why
is he there all of a sudden and like I
hate like how in the first one how they
had multiple like streams and it's like
they didn't know which one a push/pull
and it's like stick to the same thing
make sure you tell that thoroughly
because people won't come at you as hard
if you explain the story you do explain
well and not try to explain five
different stories okay and like half at
which is a good point because it looks
like they also eliminated the whole
darkness in this and they really trying
to focus on a centralized vision like
villain and in focus on specific
characters which I like in to be money's
point what I'm also hearing is that the
devs are saying like they're gonna pack
so much story in cinematics and
exposition that they say they're hoping
that we as a player get sick of it so
when I hear stuff like that I'm like
okay I have a little bit more confidence
that they're gonna try to really focus
on that and hopefully they can address
lowest-price issues with a oh but it's
like me and B me and Laura Cortney you
know it's like we said you know one of
the biggest issues I had with destiny
one is the raids kind they for the most
part they always seem to distant from
the main story of whatever they're you
know respective expansions came from
it's like you know when you went into
the orc so you know Kings fallen right
there should have been a you know one
time cinematic that after you watch it
once you could skip it every time or you
can completely turn it off entirely that
explain why you're coming here it's like
you know if people didn't know that you
know a hive king has to be killed in his
in his astral mind after you kill his
physical body no one knew that they hurt
to them it seemed like they were going
to fight Oryx twice when you weren't
fighting Oryx twice you fought him the
first time and then you had to go inside
his you know his his whole dimension and
kill him in there because a high king
cannot die unless he dies in there too
it's like I feel like they don't like
especially rise of iron no one
understood why that dude was at the end
of the raid I don't even remember ours
at the point as a good point they've got
to do a better job of transitioning the
villain into the Ray and I think it
should be easy all right I mean they
could do something as simple is your
Vanguard's talking to you over the mics
while you're doing the right explaining
what's go it's like the moment you go on
that rape all communication is up you
don't talk you're 100% right
absolutely it's like imagine like you
know they could make that more immersive
like you know you're walking up to Oryx
and you hear what's the chicks name the
one that got stuck in the tomb is eros
yeah I forgot her name it's like you
know Eris is talking she's like ice it's
him he's around he's around and the
moment you the closer you get to the
more like she is getting distorted and
she just completely cuts then you see
Oryx climb the wall like imagine how
much immersive if you would have like
you know she's talking she's building up
that the height that you're about to get
and then you see his big ass climb the
[ __ ] the opportunities a day to
potentially I'm gonna jump in real quick
but um yeah I mean I think all the doors
locked it out the park the money knocked
it out the park I mean I'm all in the
same boat when I touch the story mission
you know I was just very happy to have
centralized character focus thought that
was cool you know um yeah see Cora had a
moment like a golf failing it's it he's
worried you know we are not weeks almost
like a pretty much is the traveler
blessed humanity when they don't deserve
it's like why would you pick like you
you don't deserve your week and one of
the best things found out the Lord demon
we had this conversation is that I like
what he roof your goals like he would
your goals because that you know like a
crutch and then kicks you ate to me it
was like he's pretty much like even with
light you're still worthless exactly so
I love that whole bit and just kind of
like the rebuilding thing and then
obviously story wise it give us a reason
why you note I was blowing up happens of
being on you know as far as the gameplay
itself felt the gameplay was really
I got one negative no as far as on like
the motor play was great tactical I
think class abilities change the gaming
war like having the riffs now you don't
say the Titans with the berries I know
hunters some hunters a little upsell or
sinister knows not necessarily feeling
the Dodge but a lot of people shout the
bots who shout out the zero lord demon
that are hunters and they're like look
that dodge when you get the automatic
reload is there they wouldn't find it
saying that the class is all about
evasion now and if you master that you
can you know what the agility and stuff
is going to be great it's like you know
like the way I see that hunters are
supposed to be you know use this you
know you you're in a one-on-one gunfight
and you know both of you run out of ammo
you just shades that BAM he's done
because you just reloaded your ammo and
if you're fighting a Titan he's gonna
take a second so you literally have an
advantage because you have two clips
pretty much yeah
so um you know but that what that whole
being said you know I thought for people
I actually was in agreement will be
money coming in I'm like I don't know
about fours I'm gonna be honest I was
very skeptical about fours
I love sixes and when I played it almost
forgot about for a while
like it just I guess it felt balanced in
the sense that I didn't have to worry
about just random dudes popping the
corner with a super you know getting
jumped every time I thought you're
having four less supers means a lot yeah
I felt tactics we play a factor and it
went back to primary gunplay like in a
sense they're like you know before with
destiny it's like I don't know they
stick your name one hit kill you I'll do
all this other like kind of I don't call
it cheap but that one hit kill
foolishness where you don't even get it
the slave is in a heavy slot I felt is
huge because now and then the other
little nuance is when you go get that
heavy it's only for that one individual
now the boss in a chat but it's like
like that to me like so now you know
it's not like everyone just sitting
there campfire and around the heavy box
and we all good like know like somebody
can come and take the heavy now
that one person benefit so it just adds
another layer to it so I'm really cool
with it ultimately though I'm gonna do
it I will agree with be money in this
though I want six is fine but how six is
how do you feel about that be money yeah
I think I think the sixes are necessary
man especially I mean you know I mean
once once everybody gets in there and
they got you know all the great loot and
stuff like that I mean if you can trash
so but you know it's like you know
they've done this in the past it's like
look like if you do competitive forty
four if you do casual six be six like
it's not hard
they did it in halo but it wasn't six it
was five you know 5v5 for casual
playlist and 44 for competitive yeah so
yeah I'm excited to see where they're
gonna go with it story-wise and and
obviously the raid you know we call and
see where they go with that but that's
pretty much what I got on it unless the
uh no it's got anything else they want
to add with any uh improvements to the
destiny to beta and I'll see the social
space is available right now but of
course everyone's in the chat
not gonna do that is they gonna listen
to the IOP right artists ours laughing
actually when I was this famous or they
can't go quickly about the the inverted
spire was like some of that platforming
is like suspect like they need to I
don't know that whole part where you had
to like like blow up the turbines and
you couldn't really see where you had to
go and then you climb like some of the
platforming I don't know if in destiny
one it was crisper or it was just
exploration that you want an exploration
right fine just did it right now and I
have some dudes that got lost I don't
know where they went
they went strictly to the right and I
just went straight through the hole and
it just well I know you could yeah you
can walk around you don't necessarily
have to go one direction you could just
you can mess around and then follow the
the story path in the in the in the
strike but it would just say it was just
certain things like in terms of the
platform how is that a place so lost I
we got a little bit more than to
convince you seeing that the destined to
beta out of our system we're gonna move
on and I want to bring this over some
more King to my dismay I'm sorry guys I
did not know that splatoon launched on
Friday I'm sorry I'm guilty guilty as
charged but grandpa Nintendo in
launching of splatoon launched their
vaunted chat system Nintendo reinvented
the wheel fellas like the will we had
wasn't good enough but their will is
made of a square what was the thinking
like I really oh I know it's convoluted
also shout out to me because I told
y'all in the beginning I said listen all
the devs the saying that they don't have
that chat feature and everybody was like
now you just plug it into the top and
you it has a audio jack and slice it so
Jack and I'm gonna buy the headset we
went on about this for a long period of
time and he was like there's no way that
tells us to come on
listen they are that stupid I have the
fax the ready say they think they are as
stupid as we thought they were I said
just wait see you will see there was no
bad guys there was no no I'll pee bad it
was just so I wanted to be real but what
what what I'm getting from a lot of the
devs and a lot of the community is the
factual nature about the system now the
fact that this app for those people that
don't know you need to have your phone
the headset and a switch okay you need
to have all three devices for you to
have the chat function in game only
imagine having like six or seven people
using the switch it's gonna look like a
data room the problem with this is not
in the menu system not then outside of
gameplay does the chat works it only
works in gameplay hmm so not outside of
the boot up you can get together how
we're talking it doesn't work it only
works in game that within itself is a
huge problem and I thought it was just a
smaller problem with the fact that you
needed to use your cell phone now what
Nintendo wanted to do is take away the
processing power from the system because
the system is underpowered when it comes
to these next generation games that we
take for granted that you know have the
chat and stuff like that now I know
everybody is saying but the 360 did it
and it's which is more powerful than the
360 the PlayStation 2 had some form of
whatever and it's more powerful to the
pickety is more powerful than that what
Nintendo did not put inside the system
is it can receive it cannot give you
understand from
understand that's what I'm looking for
my understanding is is either one or two
things we still know ones not entirely
sure far as like obviously we know from
a memory standpoint they should be able
to do the inside comes down to from an
OS and a multitasking standpoint was
that in place that they can actually
have something in the background because
when I hear things like if you have the
chat at on but you get a phone call that
that voice chat disconnects like yes to
me is just poor poor like soft proper
software program like I don't understand
how that works so to me I would hate to
say that they unable to do that because
clearly they have the resource it has
more resources than Evita more resources
than all these older antiquated systems
that was able to do it so why can't they
do it to me that's the big question and
that's the mystery still a little bit in
my thought of it to be honest with you I
don't think I don't look at Nintendo as
far as pushing the boundaries and
technical excellence as far as
capabilities of what a system can do um
and when I expound on that you see how
you pull up the menu system inside your
xbox and your Xbox to multitask while
bringing in a signal from the TV while
also remembering what she was watching
on YouTube let's go right back into the
u2 app and it goes right back into the
video that she was watching it was like
it paused that video but you went and
you played a quick game and you came
back and it was still there or you
dumped into another app and you saw like
stars or something and you went back and
that other app was still there the day
for some reason don't have the engineers
that built a user interface that was
able to do the multitasking or they
don't deem it important yeah we don't
get into shout alone flashback of the
chat he said of an indigenous to each
other
honestly man I think the most
disappointing thing about this whole
thing is that you have DNA right there
in your backyard doing all of your
mobile gaming these guys are next
wizards multitasking with mobile
platforms what are you doing why would
you not let them get in there and just
make sure this ami works properly it
doesn't make any sense it just doesn't
make any sense I don't care what kind of
BS Reggie throws out that they wanted
they you know that what they wanted to
do with the platform it wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't feasible for them Oh Bible for
them to do it they wanted to make sure
that that experience was separate from
that and like Lord King said they may
not think is that important um the
problem is that when you released when
you leave something like this this this
undercooked peripheral and this whole
undercooked undercooked certain you
release it with a game that primarily
supports it that with a game that would
thrive even more with that functionality
in place and then so what you're saying
is that you don't care about all the new
people that are gonna be invested in
splatoon and a Mario Cart and all that
stuff you just speaking to the people
that were used to hard work before on
the Wii U it just doesn't make any sense
man it just honestly like so inside is
they take two steps forward and it's
take three back sometimes like watch
because it's just look at that when you
look at that peripheral a big giant like
you know who's doing that that's right
alright so I need you to top me off the
edge load B money what was what's going
on when in turn no in this act unless
you have impressions when the news came
out which is
you know like when they first announced
a switch like I'm like alright you know
everything's gonna be good you know that
they had that headphone jack on you know
some chat on there like everything's
good and then it came out with the news
like didn't have no Bluetooth they can
have an app for chat I'm like okay so
maybe that's just like you know you got
to use your phone for like a mobile
hotspot so if you go out in a park is
home now you can still get in with your
boys you know it means to be able to
check and then I was like no that's the
only way to check my work oh it's like
every time they're like we're not done
17 a bike nothing came out like five
years ago got Chad on it like yes yeah I
mean you or you know me at least the
Vita you could chat on like why this
that the Vita that like no games on it
you know I mean they move content on it
just came out 2017 like it makes
absolutely no sense
absolutely you know I mean there's like
you know I'm getting in there I'm doing
my thing but like my other people I'm
playing with they don't really
understand objectives so it's like I
can't even send my message I can't even
send a message I'm just like yo what's
going on makes absolute like okay so we
understand we all in agreement this is
the stupidest decision my question is
why though what I want us to dig deeper
light as was like when the roundtable
like why do you think they are so
antiquated with this specific function I
have a theory but I want
oh no the only reason my dear is this I
think that it's almost like a internal
struggle like there's the new Nintendo
right who makes this great device the
switch for all intensive purposes is an
amazing it's amazing tech right it's
really vice in the functionary they can
do you've got this other branch Nintendo
that does the bonus stuff like Laura
kawaii box we effectually call calvin
anybody that makes stupid decisions in
the system and it uses separate from the
device and then if you get a call you
your voice chat in the rubber you don't
like that well Calvin work says he works
that half the price of the real good
always works up to the cost and they
paid Calvin to get in it's not to be the
old regime and the only thing I could
think of in shout to spawn wave media he
made a video recently in and shokyo I
want to give him a shout to um is that I
think they're still in this mindset that
we are a kids device and we want to
separate that and not make it easy for
the kids to jump online like I still get
this feeling like you know call me if
you think I'm wrong here that they are
still in that battle and this is why
they're going these extra steps to try
to isolate the situation like what do
you feel about all this then come back
to me what do you feel about the
argument towards like parental controls
and them trying to
family system I think there's definitely
still some some power control over at
Nintendo yeah I mean it is the tug of
war is definitely still going on there
you know I mean they do like three good
things and then they do one orbiting a
net you know I mean defeats the whole
purpose of three good things they just
did so you're giving them the three good
things yeah I mean one good thing in
five things to back it which is the
games that they release have been you
know I mean top top sellers every time
circle I mean like I gotta give him
credit there but I mean when it comes to
this this you know the voice chat like
this is not totally unacceptable I don't
know who's working over there you know
in the offices I don't understand it I
don't know definitely a power struggle
and hopefully the new regime takes over
in this next year because I tell you
they don't get it right in this next
year and 2018 going between nineteen
they can have a problem like everybody's
riding a wave right now
but the only logical explanation only
logical explanation is that when they
started developing the switch it wasn't
something that they they thought of from
the beginning so implementing it now
it's not an easy thing to do that's the
only logical thing and honestly the fact
that they even started developing this
we put out this sort of stuff in mind is
again it's a Nintendo thing they're not
thinking about it um so but beyond that
in terms of in terms of them wanting to
keep it more kid-friendly
I can sort of see that but at the same
time to me the most important thing to
Nintendo beyond you know putting out
their hardware to me is their software
is the IP and the flood a cloud they've
allowed you know youngbloodz to get in
there and start developing on their
their beloved IP and don't think really
soft think it was a huge thing from
Nintendo like that tomato showed growth
to allow Marilu to be on an ex-con kind
of IP for you that would not first be
done before with Nintendo I just mean
open the third-party developers like you
said lost I was making a great point
they do things that you say
Ben this is innovative this is growth
this is them getting with the times
blue - from the box this is a goal it's
something fundamentally wrong with you
system but there's no blue - thank you
something deeper than that because if
you look at it to me they they have a
stranglehold over everything they do so
all these same old dudes had a hand in
this DNA thing that they had with mobile
gaming and I hoped oh oh slew of
different things like you know with
miitomo with Pokemon go Mario run then
open exposing themselves out there this
is something that they never allowed to
happen before and so it's like it's me
it's like it's these same guys making
those decisions so to me like I said the
only logical thing is that it's
something they can't actually implement
because of how they develop the system
from the jump
the only thing that makes anything how
otherwise it is a pity
how about this how about you sell a
headset a Nintendo proprietary made
headset with Plantronics shoutout to
Plantronics electronics with a Bluetooth
adapter that fits at the top of the
switch that can receive and send send me
up the discord or Skype app on the damn
system the system you said they should
just start bundling in Xbox
user
predators voice check because that's the
only way you're getting well they're
using the Xbox servers aren't they using
the service for the cross play game or
what am i yeah so it's not far-fetched
you just said something is probably very
viable to them
we shall see but later there's over
there over to work on a user interface
about that all right
I'm gonna try to go on a two people ran
all right it's gonna be hard but I don't
get like look like they take a step
forward and then they jump two
staircases back and take a step four and
jump two staircases but what is the
point in having an online infrastructure
of anything if I mean they're like oh
they're only charge you $20 I wouldn't
give five dollars for that piece of [ __ ]
service like look how much I just don't
I just don't understand like you can't
send party unless this is how this which
should work all right you you log on you
know it should have you know achievement
trophy support and their you know their
own little thing it's fine even a lot
like we don't even ask for a lot we just
want to have like this same you know not
on the same par even it's like this is
what I expect in this way its
touchscreen I expect to get on the
switch and be like oh look lord Cognito
is on click his little thing his profile
pops up click send invite to party and
then it goes to my phone and it starts a
party and it sends him an invite to his
phone from Saul but you know what they
want you to do all right I'm playing
escapist to when it comes out for the
switch Laura kognito is playing splatoon
so it's like oh do you want to you want
to be so I got it it's like they have
game check who hasn't apt to have game
chat I don't get that it should it
should be cross-platform chat across the
board in the background point-blank you
know like what's the point it's like
regardless what how successful the
switch is doing this something like this
is a deal breaker to me it is and it's
like after I seen this cuz you can
you guys remember I said on this podcast
multiple times that I do not I'm not
gonna completely lash out at the app I
want to see what the app is I said you
know it could be a revolutionary thing
it could you know it can make its
competitors do something where you are
being patient and yeah but you know they
I understand why they do that because
it's horrible it's not your average day
console it's portable so they wanted be
able to take that experience with you
wherever you go and everyone's got a
smartphone so I can understand why they
wanted an app okay but what it needed to
be done is it needs to be you know it
needs to be background Apple and he's
been playing the background doesn't do
that I don't know why they thought that
was a good idea so that's all righty
that's pretty much automatic don't you
think at some point in time being that
is some app that they can do maintenance
to that and update that from time I
don't care that should be done launched
they already get a strike
you can't use an app for a party feature
and make it where any app let you get a
text BAM you're done I'm like I don't
get that messenger you have to be you
get a message on messenger so you have
to leave the app go reply your messages
then go back on the app you get a phone
call bam you're done off the app like it
makes no sense by that you know like
what they should have been like you know
you've been like you know five or six
tiles it's like you know set up your
party city points everyone say in the
beginning of the app that the app is
very jealous and selfish shits are
selfish
Nintendo to me is gotten to the point
with me like every day it's something
negative every day every time I see
these people on the news it's something
negative way and let's just slow that
down back
let's backtrack what Olive News has
been- outside of the Nintendo chat
what's what's positive besides the sales
of their games well they've been
dropping game so what's good man - two
armed besides games
that's what you gain system making games
let's see you're talking about cells
into way it's a game system five months
we have cells or two games that's all
you have that your entire they have no
interaction with Netflix and who they
don't have any kind of so we talked
about they're gonna do that because it's
not exposing me every time that they
talk about anything that is open and
standard for the twenty 21st century
it's always negative Nintendo is so far
behind I'm really to be honest with you
guys they'll never catch up it doesn't
matter by the time what's gonna happen
is they're gonna be to 21st century [ __ ]
we're gonna be doing like what do you
say accent or that question I hear where
you're coming from
let's get that out there swept away in
Lord Chief Tommy's made a real good
point so obviously Xbox we had a topic
of cough while back about systems that
drop that have all these features right
I believe it was lord King okay so
basically comes down to do you want your
system to be a game focused or do you
want your system to be apt and future
focused and based on what you're saying
but in this sense hold on let me finish
in this sense here the complete opposite
Xbox because the cry of Xbox right now
is they don't have any original IP right
that's the word on the street right
let's say that Xbox has dropped in bomb
games but they had no party system they
had no infrastructure have a multiplayer
right they had only game chat through an
app would not care about their games
there say why can't I do the [ __ ] I'm
doing on place like that but that that's
a feature that's important to you right
that's not you that's important in
gaming necessarily because he's so game
game chat party chat friends list you
any interaction with messaging that's
not important to gaming there are some
people look at that the sails reflect
that despite all these things that you
want and that you're complaining about
SS still buying switch I'm just away
because I want them to douche but you
but here's the thing in this sense you
are the minority in the sense that the
people still don't care what you're
saying they're still buying it still
buying it that's why I'm trying to say
so the people have spoken that it's not
as important as you think it is
it's a 2017 product and the PlayStation
4 is already starting to beat it every
month I guess we just say could agree on
this conversation agree no I just think
no I just think it's one of the things
where we all have our priorities as to
what we want from a system you know
you're in for lore daddy I get it he's
like you know I want party chat I want
these features I want apps I want all
these things and I get it you know so
for him he's cooling on it because he's
like look you guys should have been had
this this is a big blow to him and don't
I'm not gonna minimize this it's a huge
blow to people who on the fence also I
would say community it's a blow to 60 to
70% of the pockets it's basic stuff that
its competition has been thriving for
for the past 15 years it's a brand new
product come out for five go it's it
should cool off then now now that this
information is out right they shouldn't
win another NPD again per you
'i'm here selling it because the app
addict is not a disown him no I mean
today is anybody walking out the door
saying alright let me get rid of this
system because I can't chat with my
friends yeah okay let's let's look at it
for the matter that's myself
no it's having almost identical pass
that the Wii U hat I'm not going no the
first year the Wii you got to like
follow for it was like eight million in
the first like two years of the of its
cycle and then it just don't you have
the software lineup that the the switch
has a per month and for the rest of the
but we're talking about their shoes
we're talking about cells right okay so
they're nothing so we determine when
it's different than the wheel when the
window when do I get to say it is not
the same what do you need to see from
the switch that we can say now it's a
definitive success it is different from
when you tell me what I wants the
criteria so I can meet it and we can
have it and I respect that and I'm just
I just want to know when is the criteria
that I win this that I say it's
different it's successful it's better
than the Wii U and it's gonna be around
that's what I wanna know so tell me what
I need to have for my criteria for this
bed bundling watch my caller with this
or we go to another topic
let's go because we actually want too
much of a tangent again the Lords get a
little hot and heavy five guys a lot at
ignite trying to go for them you know we
get passionate sometimes but let's move
on this is will go on all day with the
switch app and everything the
foolishness of grandfather intend Oh
Lord sovereign let's um get into the
news with Casey
Hudson what's been going on with with
our Lord Casey there I bring it to you
yes this past week um it was announced
that the Bioware GM Erin Flynn was
stepping down after a number of years at
the company and replacing him was going
to be Casey Hudson coming back after
leaving Bioware three years ago to go
work on um hololens at Microsoft and now
he's coming back as the GM sort of take
over the reins of what Bioware is gonna
be moving forward I think considering
considering the reception that Mass
Effect Andromeda got um the timing is a
little kind of a I guess I guess good
for Bioware or because it seems even you
know even if you can't put the onus of
everything that happened with uh with
Mass Effect on erin-flynn um the fact
that you have a name like Casey Hudson
coming back the director of all three
original Mass Effect games a director of
Kotor and Jade Empire I guess the the
perception is that having this guy at
the helm now is gonna write the ship for
Bioware in terms of producing quality
story driven games especially with
anthem coming out the expectation is
that now with Casey Hudson back that the
foot you know the the handprint that
he's gonna put on anthem is gonna put it
over the top and with people talking
about how anthem is in the same vein as
something like like a destiny and and
all the criticisms weighed against
destiny about not having story and what
they're doing with destiny to I think
it's at least as a to show that they
have a vested interest in making anthem
the best product that can be the fact
that Casey Hudson is back means a lot to
people who care about Bioware and
Bioware games it's a big it's a big step
to me it's a big step and it's a it's a
big positive absolutely the Lord's want
to jump in this on the Katy Hudson
returning to Bioware news well I'm
waving the flag happy that he's showing
up because I didn't purchase Andromeda
and then purchase a homonym from the
standpoint of what I saw what was going
on
the fact when they switched over to the
Frostbite engine it just stuff looked
off at first I mean the Frostbite engine
don't get me wrong as a fantastic engine
but also know that growing pains from
jumping from one engine to the next
engine will be evident and it was
evident in the facial features of a lot
of the characters and the blank stares
you know it took away from the story
from what I was hearing what I was
reading leading up to the launch of the
game so if something doesn't sit well
with me I'm not gonna give them my money
I'm gonna vote with my dollars and I'm
going to wait for it to come aside EA
access that's what I'm yeah yeah when
the game launches in the air access then
I see like but if I don't see that an
issue or here initial positive things
about games and all I'm hearing is
negative on top of negative I'm not
gonna give the money and the fact that
Casey is coming back and he's the
originator of the the first three um
yeah I'm down with that and I love Jade
Empire so hopefully with him at the helm
Jade Empire can actually get a release
and that'd be nice for us so I think
it's in great hands and yeah yeah I
think the company needs this kick
because Andromeda was such such a
disappointment and I know it was a
disappointment sales-wise and I know a
lot of Darrell's lost a job because of
Andromeda absolutely Lord be money what
do you feel about the Casey Hudson
announcement to valuing I'm just glad
he's coming back you know I mean like
he's kind of bouncing around a little
bit the past couple years
you know Jade Empire was was my first
Bioware game and that's you know I mean
I got a much for Jade Empire been that
game to return and I talked to Michael
alo who who also works over at AE a nice
he's one of the guys who who kind of run
the Dragon Age team and stuff like that
and you know he keeps he keeps the fire
lit that you know Jade Empire may come
back one day so hopefully with Casey
coming back and then shelf and Mass
Effect for a while we might see that but
um you know I got super excited
he was at Microsoft for a while because
I thought you know maybe you know he
would do something there and then he was
put on the hololens team and I mean yeah
element you know I mean for me because I
mean he's such a great you know I mean
visionary for games and putting you know
great stories out there that thought it
was kind of wasted you know I mean for
me on Halloween
absolutely 1,000% agree with you you
know I mean so I'm glad he's back at VA
he's at the helm you know this does mean
a lot for anthem because a lot of the
interviews they talked about how anthem
may not have that in depth of a story
it's more about you know playing with
your friends and having fun and things
like that so hopefully you know he
steers that ship in a different
direction
give us some deep lore and give this
something to build on because it is
supposed to be a 10 year game similar to
what destiny is soli really flushes that
out but you know hopefully this means a
lot for Mass Effect 2 yeah I mean so
hopefully you know they they can write
the ship there and and maybe you know
reboot it again I don't know if they'll
come out with them grandmother to work
wherever the case is but maybe they'll
look to take that in a different
direction
Microsoft let him a Lafont because
usually when people whose contracts and
stuff is up like that hits the gaming
news the you know here it says someone
go go somewhere else because he's a big
name in the industry so I mean the fact
that you didn't hear nothing it's like
then Microsoft let him out of a contract
to have good ties in VA still I'm
assuming he had he went over there to be
able to say listen I'm you know we're
gonna do this on a year-to-year basis
and I don't I don't I don't know because
when he went over there wasn't really
sign of desperation but you know he he's
got a big background he said I will not
do games he pretty much said that I want
to spend time with my family I do not
want to work on games and going to
Microsoft and having someone as big as
talented as him it's like you know
there's there has to be a reason
Microsoft took him I don't know if it
was like you know they figure
maybe he would spend a little bit time
on you know via uh you know their
homeland and then maybe go to a studio
like there's a lot of people having
videos and stuff to like I understand
what Microsoft would have a talent like
him a web-based I don't think that was
Microsoft's that that was Microsoft's
choice like he's a big talent regardless
yeah I'm gonna jump in on his to lawn
attic I'm actually gonna be streaming
with you because you know shout-out to
Lobby money what he said as far as him
being put on the hololens project i
thought that was a waste I was like you
gotta get this big talent and this is
what he's gonna be doing you know that
kind of thing but then his defense
personally he didn't want to work on
games anymore like what exit but then
for him now to just you know obviously
get be able to get out of that situation
from Microsoft and now come back to
borrow it to me again this is me
guessing I'm inferring I have no inside
information I just feel that I think by
where muster back the truck up because
if you look at what's been going on with
Mass Effect in drama drama right and the
negative reception just the future of
the series let's be honest I'm the
Andromeda did have some scars and it
definitely affected the future and now
the whole focus is now directed towards
anthem so you now have now hazy Hudson
back on board now would buy away as a
holdover I don't think she's gonna have
a whole lot of fingerprints on anthem I
think they're right it's already in
place it's already but it'll get to
touch a little bit you know he'll get
maybe get a little a compliment but I
agree with you it's that's already del
balón is done and I think ultimately I
think this really both this is Mike I
really think it really bodes well for
Mass Effect's future to come back and
that means what I care about the most
honestly don't mean it don't get me
wrong
anthem I feel I'll be honest you know
I'm a destiny guy and all these dudes
out here coming back pretty much
guaranteed at Mass Effect's coming
eventually like my feet wouldn't have
came back I think Mass Effect might have
died yeah I agree
I think Mass Effect was DOA and when I
again this is all speculation is all
opinion and I think this was their way
to kind of get the original 18 guys he
was the 18 this was the high Mass Effect
not this be team of devs and all this
other stuff and it doesn't hurt to have
anthem you know
I'm over looking at and even when Adams
already that's how I'm just going back
to the the reason why he was on hololens
I mean I think that was on him I mean he
again was yeah yeah he's absolutely I
mean he started out his degrees in
mechanical engineering so haha you know
he wanted to go fit to work on that tech
um both from a hardware and software
perspective and yeah so it wasn't you
know it's not the same rigors as being
you know the director of a game where
you you know you basically have no time
to yourself so actually that's wrong
work on your leverage born into that
situation to say what I wanted to do I
think the most exciting be besides the
fact that him coming back gives some
hope to mass effect coming back on also
star wars man like Star Wars obviously
we won't get a coat or because both
court or games are not canon and since
Disney took over yeah and properly every
project they put out they wanted to be
Anton so but the fact that there still
is no talk of a new Star Wars RPG all
these other Star Wars games that are
coming out or shooters are you know
third-person action games with Amy
Hennings game like there's no RPG and in
this anybody that you want to put that
type of game in front of it's a Casey
Hudson so do you think this of his
return was because he saw his his child
that he helped make being butchered in
the street and just left for dead and
said well you know I'll go back and help
nurse it back to life or something
because I mean it must have hurt him to
see him like the fact that remember he
he has such great success with masters
been wanting to and he caused such flack
for three because they ending at 33 for
all until the purposes is a great game
right but ending in a game
and he's the one got out in front of
that he's the one that took the brunt of
the punishment for that stuff he he took
it on there in from everybody for that
so the fact that
they would weather that even though like
me personally I didn't like the fact
that they retcon that stuff and then put
it on and be nothing like that you just
stick to your guns man you know you know
that's it it was too much flak man I was
about to say shout-out to the fact that
he put that deal that just the fact that
they went down the wig went down and the
fact that he had to respond to that but
he took it on the chin so Eve and for
them to continue on and then it just
seems like they didn't they didn't
realize that the mistakes they made with
that and and try to make it better they
just sort of gave you a middling product
and again I mean there's been a lot of
speculation as to why that happened and
development cycle for that game or
whatnot so yeah absolutely if he has the
opportunity to resurrect it and bring
mass effect back to where it was yeah I
would take that opportunity absolutely
absolutely great topic so let's move on
to the next one and I want to bring this
over to a lord be money himself they
want to talk about holiday releases
right be money what's going on with [ __ ]
topic yeah man so the topic that I want
to bring to the table was you know is
the holiday release as important as it
used to be with with so many more games
released in early spring now you know
does it make more sense for more games
released in the spring and is the
holiday season you know as important
yeah I mean when you look at the last
holiday season and even this holiday
season it seems like we mostly just got
the big shooter you know from Microsoft
we had Forza you know that stands out
every year because that kind of releases
a little bit earlier before the actual
holiday season comes up or or it's
considered to be holiday season so um
but when you look at the the holiday
season it's mostly just filled with you
know your Call of Duty's your
battlefields Battlefront now since that
has come back but other than that I mean
there's there's not too many big games
um you know super big games that you
look forward to in a holiday season a
lot of them have been pushed to the
spring and you know just looking at this
year this year springless was crazy and
you look into the next year the next
year spring is crazy you know we got we
got Red Dead and Far Cry and you know
some of the biggest games from
PlayStation and even you know Microsoft
has moved some their games his brain
with you know see if thieves and you
know state of decay so a lot of big
games coming out of beginning a year and
not so much at the end of the year so I
just want to see what you guys take was
on that you know the game industry is
absolutely wrong at the same time the
income tax
somebody shout out to every developer
and every big company that said yo this
is the time where there's a lot of free
cash back into the system get back in
here so that's me when I'm telling you
has everything to do with disposable
income at that period of time and they
know that the game seals the switch
floor the shells from ghetto bugs
holiday shows are always gonna mean more
than you know the games that sell the
most every year is always in holiday so
do you think like money was saying do
you feel like dead people should just
stick with their guns as far as
developers and publishers actually
release about if you don't think your
game is on the caliber to compete in the
holidays you gotta move your day amen
with nine times out of ten the games
that sell the most that every year comes
out in the holiday because those are the
blockbusters there's a reason no one
wants to touch Call of Duty in November
clothes are Christmas gifts nobody's
right though I mean yeah I agree I mean
it's finished yeah I think it's one of
those things where I think this is a
great topic it's one of those things
where we got those established franchise
like a scene OD or whatever that drop in
November or Assassins and stuff and
people are going to back down has no
business being out in November it's a
tough one it's a tough one
I agree cuz one days it's the seventh
day not when when is Call of Duty
Arwen's you know is they released a
quantity is it before 13 you're gonna
get like a week to rock and I always get
concerned with stuff like that because
I'm like when you're so close to the sea
OD I was called like the sea OD
affecting neighboring damaged leg you
need to speak yeah you know so
especially any type of shooter whatever
so I mean I do feel that I do agree with
rocky you know I think spring is the new
way I think that um you know that them
tax dollars do come in and they do most
was this one thing
I actually hate about being a gamer
especially at the last three years is
that when all the big dams can pubs
realistic games all bunched up no family
I think income tax has a part to do with
it but I think the main reason is
because they know they can't compete
with Call of Duty battlefield like you
know they want their game mountain
holiday like that is the ideal release
date this because maps are going out
buying Christmas presents that's the
ideal so but you know then when they're
like well let's delay it because we
can't compete with quality you can't
compete with battlefront too we can't
compete with these November and all
september/october big hits why do you
think there's really nothing coming out
to beating a Sikh temple cuz no one
thinks they can compete with destiny
just my words so they're like thieves is
backed by H&R Block you know we can
delay it because will underperform in
the holidays you know what we'll put it
out there towards you know the middle to
the beginning of the because a lot of
times if a game is delayed out of a year
it comes out in January February that's
usually when it comes out so you know
they're like you know what we'll get
around the same times that uh you know
people are getting their in and contacts
back and you know we will do decent day
and there's some games that come out at
like the first couple days of January
ended up selling millions of copies I
think I guess a - I grew up to me I
respect where the publishers like look
we're gonna move the date like don't do
the titanfall - like don't put your
title out in the space where you know
you're not gonna be able to compete or
just realistically get the most revenue
for said game so it's like I actually
like when a company humbles themselves
say you know what we're gonna move like
I just look at cases like 10-4 - I'll
look amazing it was amazing and you sit
there like why do they do it to
themselves this [ __ ] you should have the
flexibility to
and me personally like I said before
like I actually like when stuff gets
pushed back to that you know
february-march area because again I
always feel November is just too
cluttered sometimes you know and I just
like that spacing out of games and
having like black box tears at the top
of the yeah I mean look we had this year
right we had horizon zero dawn and we
had you know yeah you're a neo and
celled all these great games but we even
made a topic we were like you know has
the game buddy have been released
already and we even remember early you
did that so to me that that's the wave I
just be personal but the rest of the
Lord's think about it I think every
developers should look at him a month
month I don't think it was just Ubisoft
I think every dev was happy Red Dead two
got away
absolutely like their two best selling
games released early in the year for us
shoutout Farnum I give it up to when I
gotta give it up baby those numbers came
in and he was looking kind of rosy over
there it's bit between either arguing -
you two ever that use absolutely right
100% they no but I do like the fact that
the masses have went back to the game
and showed that this content in the game
that they like and and in this shows it
shows the diversity in our whole
conglomerate of game players here that
we can't go back to games that are
released months before and those numbers
do show that it is viable which is so
Janacek he also said I know he thinks
fours is gonna be safe for the holiday
release but he's concerned and Lucky's
tale might get destroyed for lucky tell
people are gonna pick it up when they
want to pick it up it's a cheap title so
you know a lot of people hit up anyway
was it at least a 4 super lucky I don't
know
anybody knows - game should be in a box
right November 7th published in
Microsoft Studios down is selling more
than 22 no bet with that I don't care
what you say with 25 individual to you
because you're not buying so you're not
in the conversation no yeah you buy
crack down on a regular Xbox I'll talk
about to us elite player players is
playing the Xbox one X I guess I guess
so like you need that to make yourself
in the lead play
you actually Lord addict this is you and
I want to talk about that in 64 mini
possibly some chirping in these streets
with school knows apparently there has
been a trademark that's leaked the n64
controller is being trademarked again so
you know obviously I mean Nintendo could
be making it in 64 controller for the
hell of it but I think you can all agree
they're using it for another product so
you know chances are we're going to get
a 64 MIDI next year and you know what I
wanted to ask is if you could pick any
15 games to go on that what would it be
and you know low kognito on River in
bring the Atari up in this but I mean
you guys want to talk about that [ __ ]
you can talk about that I really care
about the nothing box nothing could have
I think they could give me that free
mean 64 I'll jump in on this one yes 64
that's some great memories man wow
that's actually different because I'm in
cities that mario64 we had all those you
know big titles but it's Lord Sovereign
Lord kind of odd sinister no oh yeah
holds a different place in my heart for
different reasons I was all about them a
key wrestling games
[Music]
it was limited like it was so savage we
would make our own pay-per-views yeah
Lord King but we would have wrestling
tournaments every weekend and 64 Aki
wrestling games right and whoever won is
- so you didn't want to lose the
championship man and then how we did it
was like we would do like a match type
before like like I almost like a battle
royal and then Wellington's deliberated
in the final two will face each other
then we put up the names in a hat with
what type of meso sometimes
triple-decker come up and the person who
lost in the battle room get another
chance for dragging your leg under the
rope so anyway stayed outside of the
ring
slicing whoever was still in that so you
already eliminated you in your feelings
before for me is the wrestling games man
and I doubt the beginner bring those
back I'm assuming that's a licensing
actually those those those licenses are
all up in the air trust me I was as soon
as I heard this I looked into it there's
they're up in the air there's a good
chance they'll be on it then
Oh shadow only nummis out of heaven no
mercy was the best period do you know
that let's go no the problem is they
might be able to get the engines in but
in terms of Licensing for specific
wrestlers and stuff like that like
obviously like the the W the games have
crisp
line it like stuff like that like
there's a whole bunch of stuff that
needs to be and it's not worth it
money-wise but yes since we have is that
they're willing to put the engine in and
just with a blank slate engine and
that's it now here's the thing what
about for people as listen talk none 64
mini like the emulators allow like
Raspberry Pi and all that stuff right
they allow to get those back okay I was
just curious cuz I actually never seen
the old game that's been that long so a
system like for the my kids you know
because you know I'm trying to get them
at our old school gaming so I'm putting
together like a raspberry pie system
with those downloads from Nintendo 64
yes you know and the wrestling games was
like top of the list they kept the
competitive juices flowing we was
looking forward to every weekend so yeah
doctor chief Tommy Anna che said that
James Bond no it's not nobody talked
about that people say banjo kazooie and
stuff but the question is is Microsoft
won't let them do it so no if you think
about it I mean they might but if you
think about it like the majority of the
games they would put on that service is
on ray replay and I don't think they
would try to hurt the seller right
regardless you know rare replay might
not be getting a whole lot of cells but
when the you know if the by then
especially that's a year they put out
blast corpse I'm missing blast mm-hmm
that was one of my little in the corner
games you know for Nintendo 64 we know
we're gonna get Mario we're gonna
probably get Mariel Kart I think
everything that says 64 in the time but
then the last corpse was a very good
title from them and it was a very early
on tighter I think was a launch title
with them mmm-hmm I love the fact that
it was there so yeah I hope they put
less works with it what about you be my
list was your title just like someone at
exhibition I just want to say real quick
the farm is trending on Twitter okay no
check that out when those there be buddy
it was definitely the wrestling games
were number one
I was in there yeah when back with one
of my Google oh yes we vacuumed yeah
that's what the special ops people right
yeah yeah so you know stuff like that is
what you know death will be on my list
of course you know you get the Smash
Brothers that you know Mario see stuff
like that you know some of those start
third party games for 64 we're pretty
dope I mean they they had a pretty good
library you know just kind of was
overshadow but you know my playstation
but it still had it I would definitely
love to see the wrestling games come
back we can get what about our you loss
off what about your list with games you
want yeah I mean definitely I mean
honestly I had the wrestling games will
be first and foremost put that like I
said it's I looked into that and it's
that that's something that's obviously
the yeah
[Music]
physics is crazy wave race 64 water to
me looked better than wave race game to
water yeah my knee is something about it
the way it moved and the way it just
felt real like it would it was really
really good to me that that blew me away
that way bridge so one of the Buffalo it
added what's your 15 and you got a
different respect because the 60/40 you
always forget you know we got the yellow
G right here so 60/40 you represents a
different intent or like this is like
who you started with so so what's up
with with those games and the stuff
you're you looking forward to personally
I think we can guarantee go tonight is
gonna be on there we can guarantee
pokemon stadium one of them is gonna be
on there probably Pokemon snap it would
not be surprised if they put that on
there
Mario 64 definitely maybe quest 64 64 I
told you man it's gonna be a lot of 64
and they talk like it felt like anything
was 64 and his name was fire like
remember it was called ultra starfox
that's now here's the question I got
here what about but what's it 64 were
they debuted the expansion pack yeah I
would hear them as far as ohm now we
know they've got the licence for the
controller right so we think we're
getting it in its original form but you
know that that was the debut II most
people don't know that was the debut of
an analog stick yeah that was the first
analog and it changed the game because
those controls almost look like a little
battering right yeah I tell people all
the time like as much soon as we give
Nintendo like the first ones there you
know I mean everybody just kind of
iterated after it but
you know right there on the doorstep but
a lot of stuff you know I mean they put
the rumble in there too so yeah so
Rumble day 64 with the memory expansion
yeah Wow and they have it was was it one
of the earlier systems that had four
players right eye without a tap into the
system that's yeah as a co-op guy always
appreciated good memories insolence
let's talk about this being all the good
memories or slash memories tapping about
this Atari box job real quick before we
wrap this you know what was crazy um
CNN reported on it like very brief like
on like on a little passing by of it and
that's all that's how I heard about it
mmm sounds like so that's that's when I
send you that um the message because I
went deep delving into it and I said
this is for real this is not vaporware
this is not a joke this is not a game
they show two iterations of it the one
with the wood grain and the one that's
two all black with the orange um
apparently they said they're gonna be
playing current games as well I don't
know what that means
I know I know they said they're gonna be
playing old games but they said also
current games so I don't know it is
Atari trying to do some type of comeback
or something I don't know what's going
on to be honest with you because it's
like all hit at one time but I'm
definitely picking up the system Lord be
money where you at with this Atari Box
information the news that we got so far
yeah like soon as I saw that they were
gonna be paying current games like I
just need this is you control there you
know I mean that's every time you know
what type of games you're gonna have
like if it's worth a standard controller
you know I mean with you know bumpers
and triggers and buttons then it might
be one to some Atari is the old-school
company but
you know I mean they have great
relationships out there I don't know if
they you know really be able to compete
but you know that's another option for
somebody else and maybe if they come at
a lower price point you know I mean they
get people to jump in and yeah I mean
they can still play some of the current
games or wherever case is you know I'm
definitely interested in it you know I
mean I want to see where they take it
from here but you know the fact that
they're playing current games puts them
you know and people's mindset did you
see any cartridge slot in there I didn't
see a cartridge slot so I think this is
gonna be download only if from honest
and I just he says there four USB ports
an HDMI port and SD card slot and a
place to plug in the network I can't
take Atari seriously right now I'm kind
of with my dad I'm really not taking it
serious you know but it would be cool if
they do like an emulation if they kind
of follow the Nintendo format and they
kind of like give you like 2600 1700
Jaguar you know all these things but it
is the vibe that they're gonna be really
making new games anybody confirm what
this is gonna be so they date the game
they come you know the wood grain is
cool you know I mean
and then like this even the other one
the black orange join it's like okay you
know maybe they are you know trying to
kind of be in people let's see I'm good
I think when they talk about new games
it's okay to me it's an Android platform
yeah how powerful it is it's gonna be up
in the air um but like people like what
kind of said like if it's something that
plays like twenty six hundred seventy
eight hundred fifty two hundred games
and the entire battle our guy walks up
to you that's I mean that to me is a
little more appealing and the fact you
know we talk about new games I think you
know any new indie stuff you know seeing
those type of games I think would be
perfect system I just wanna I just want
to ask you guys a question maybe not a
simple question the last time you've
watched a podcaster you know seems a
tweet on Twitter you look you know what
I want like even when the in the NES
mini came out I didn't see anyone say
you know NES minis awesome I wanted an
Atari Mini that did not happen so you
know what an atari thinks you know what
nintendo making bank we going to no
you're not you're not good it's not
going to be outsold could be sold out we
got you know i mean like that's how I
felt too I go up ain't nobody trying to
buy an $80 to $120 machine to play pong
I'm sorry what you're saying like I
don't think nobody cried out for this
but it gets
the baby open the door let the baby this
is just a way of getting thanks for
coming through I know he kept you a
little bit today before we do these
outros also I want to talk about we got
a new poll coming up this week so I just
want to bring put this and everybody's
notice up on Twitter so pretty much it's
gonna be for those who are picking up
Xbox on x1d what will you wait until
November 7 to purchase the majority of
those titles for the X treatment titles
like shadow of war AC origins for the 7
are you picking them up day 1 are you
waiting so that's gonna be the new poll
that's going out we appreciate all the
support you guys are definitely rockin
and we
get these outros going so lord be money
where can the fine people find you these
days
man I'm a little bit everywhere you just
find me
that'd be money 101 on Twitter and
always check us out tick podcast chew
home so just Google that you can find us
anywhere website tick podcast you to
doubt it I appreciate you I have had a
great time
Noemi she a trooper coming through thank
you folding my bag that time I thought I
lost it III parties where we we get
Elder Scrolls me and we had the big
brontosaurus legs of Turkey so it was
always fun appreciate you may shout out
to take man you guys are doing great
things over there you guys will accept
my caboose with the coals Lord addict
we can flappy what you got cooking up
well you know what you can you know what
you won't find me doing that's by a
Minotaur so you can find me on Twitter
you know Lord addict IOP find me on
youtube gaming addict you know obviously
you can catch me here co-host and you
can catch me Tuesday at 7:30 p.m. on
kids news podcast you know host over
there on Planet X would definitely want
to do an addict spotlight this week I'm
neither gonna do it on Kingdom Hearts or
crackdown I don't know which one yet I'm
still getting a you know I'm gonna do my
attic spotlight a little bit different
this time so I'm getting everything done
ready for that but uh yeah I appreciate
everyone that definitely came in I'm
still me and the other lords are still
coming in what we we might have a
special you know special feature we're
going to do next week but you know that
we'll announce that later on so
definitely definitely follow us on
Twitter like I can't begin to describe
how you guys need to follow the Lord's
because you know besides uh you know
besides me
the other ones are entertaining I love
the plug baby I love the flow you know
eggs right next week is gonna be crazy
so you're gonna tune in for that too as
well and the Lord soft where can the
fine people find your profile these days
thanks appreciate it
Michelle that's everybody in the chat
man you guys keep it lit man just keep
everybody engaged we appreciate that and
yeah you guys can find me on PSN @bx
sovereign to one word xbox live would be
exciting two words and on Twitter Lord
saw by Opie know it real quick before
move on to the next row shout out the
fat back in the chat he said you can
also catch B money on brat baby baby
listen to you guys when I was at work
great show also so yeah shout out to
crap they always show support to the ILP
you know love you guys see what I'm
gonna see you and also we gonna get this
all to a premium experience game himself
some people can't use garbage and be as
good as you
[Laughter]
you catch your Facebook Instagram sort
of that everything is coming along
getting the podcast going getting the
videos going I have a person working on
the website going all that stuff is
coming along as it's going the animators
is doing a thing
the basement is finished so stuff is
working but I had to let everybody know
oculus dropped a price to 399 for the
system and the controller so they're
going like head-to-head with the p2p SVR
and I know you're probably saying it's
still a little bit pricey but look at
all the tech that's in that box
price-wise that VR is very viable at
this point in time just you know give a
shout out give a look go to Best Buy
check it out put it on your head I'm
pretty sure please like subscribe I'll
pee all our media outlets to SoundCloud
all the support really helps your the
chat was lit your chat has been lit the
last like three to four weeks show I
want to really support give up my props
out to you and all that really helps us
and also I want to always forget want to
give a shout out to our good friends at
playback gaming dotnet you can find all
some great articles there by some good
PPG writers and all of the ILP audio of
all our past podcast is up there so if
you listen to the ones that are no
longer on YouTube the intros the how we
started this thing used to be just a
destiny only podcast you can catch that
out and of course the sly little here we
take the love and that know